[Musik] [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
[Musik] [Applaus] [Musik] guten Abend einen
wunderschönen guten Abend hallo hallo hallle
hier im schönen Steintor ist das schöner hier sein
guten Abend das wirklich toll er ist und seid ihr
bereit ja ich hab es ist wirklich viel ich hab
das wirklich der Klopper ich habe das ganze Jahr
das ganze Jahr mitgebracht zwischen diese beiden
Deckel gepresst es war aber auch wieder was los
oder h und so viel unterschiedliches die Spaltung
der Gesellschaft der die galoppierende Inflation
der Bedrohte Wohlstand also der Wohlstand ist
komisch ich war auf vielen Weihnachtsmärkten alle
Bums voll Restaurants Bums voll mein Treppenhaus
daheim bis in fünften Stock bumsvoll mit Paketen
von sämtlichen Lieferdiensten na aber auch
aber auch natürlich auch man auch auch not
na ich bin in der Fußgängerzone an einem vorbei
der saß da so mit dem Hut in der Hand und ganz
in feinem Gewand habe ich gesagt was ist denn
bei ihnen mal schief gelaufen im Leben und da
hat er so rumgedruckt sagt ja habem ich
bin Abteilungsleiter im Finanzministerium
wir brauchen jetzt jeden Cent habe ich im erstmal
gleich 5 € aus dem Hut gemobst na und dann h der
hey war der Sauer gagt was soll das habe ich
gesagt das holt ihr euch doch ohnehin wieder
alles von mir zurück na es ist wirklich 2023 es
ist so vieles passiert na dauernd war was dauernd
kam einer wollte was fordert dies und fordert
das ich habe jetzt ja auf meinem Smartphone so
eine App installiert die warnt mich dann immer
wenn ich zwei Begriffe eingebe Söder und fordert
seitdem brauche ich keinen Wecker mehr das
geht morgens um 6 Uhr schon los es vibriert
und macht weil seit einigen Wochen kommt immer
Söder fordert Neuwahlen ja habe ich gesagt die
werden aber nicht einfach so angesetzt nur weil es
ein bayerischer Provinzfürst permanent einfordert
na da git's klare Regeln erstmal müsste der
Kanzler die Vertrauensfrage stellen und da
ist Olaf Scholz ratlos und sagt wie macht man
das und außerdem immer das mit den Wahlen wir
brauchen mehr Wahlen wir wollen neu Wahlen
Wahlen haben wir ja in diesem Jahr gesehen
Wahlen bringen nicht unbedingt die wänd zum
Besseren okay in Polen schon ne [Applaus] ja
kleiner kleiner Hoffnungsschimmer die peace ist
weg peace hat jemals eine treffendere Bezeichnung
für eine solch Rechte Demokratie verachtungst Weg
Wahlen aber sonst dann wird gewählt in Argentinien
D haben wir jetzt einen neuen Mini Trump na
den selbsternannten anarchokapitalistenvier
seltsamer Mann mit einer noch seltsameren
Frisur kurz danach die Niederlande Gert Wilders
der tulennzi den hatte ich schon hat ich völlig
ehrlich den hatte ich schon völlig vergessen
jetzt stärkste Kraft sieht diese Abfolge Boris
Johnson Donald Trump ji will das vorsicht vor
Politikern mit komischen Frisuren also von daher
antworte ich immer wenn die Frage aufkommt
ja ihr kabarettiste ihr wisst doch immer
alles besser warum geht ihr nicht in die Politik
bitte schauen sie mich an also hab wir das Erle
aber holl undtin l mal um uns um unsere
Sorgen der Schnee der Frost und dann die
Frage stehen wir vor einem Hungerwinter ja weil
die Mehrwertsteuer in der Gastronomie wieder auf
den normalen Satz zurückgeführt werden soll
die Schnitzel WN teurer das Cholesterin und
fettablagerungsdepot der Deutschen ist in Gefahr
die Ampel führt uns in den schnitzelkrieg ich
habe das locker genommen ich habe mir gesagt
h als die Steuer edingt gesenkt wurde habe
ich in keinem einzigen Restaurant bemerkt
dass das Schnitzel günstiger geworden W
warum warum bitte soll es denn dann
jetzt teurer W ne nein da glaube
ich ganz an die selbstregulierenden Kräfte
des freien Marktes und unserem finanzfuchs
Lindner Angst vor der drohenden Staatspleite
nehmen weil da diese 60 Milliarden die für
coronahilfen gedacht waren nicht abgerufen
wurden und dann umgewidmet wurden für den
Klimaschutz eigentlich gute Idee aber meine Güte
und umgewidmet hey wir hatten vor Jahren mal eine
Ökosteuer die dann für die Finanzierung der
rierrente gebraucht wurde die Sektsteuer
vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg eingeführt war für
den Bau von U-Booten gedacht der der Erste
Weltkrieg ist lange vorbei aber die Sektsteuer
gibt's immer noch nur wo sind die U-Boote na
[Applaus] jetzt und jetzt ja jetzt mussten ganz
schnell 17 Milliarden her um den Haushalt 2024
zu ermöglichen da hat sich Winfried Kretschmann
sofort zu Wort gemeldetag ich verstehe gar nicht
warum sich der Lindner wegen der paar Milliarden
immer so ins Hemd macht was kriegt man denn heute
noch für 17 Milliarden gerade mal einen lausigen
Bahnhof in Stuttgart meine Güte ehrlich ich
doch [Applaus] immer es war wirklich so viel
2 20 23 man muss sich ab und zu schon auch mal
der Realität entziehen sonst habe ich hältst du
das doch alles nicht mehr aus manche Dinge muss
man sich einfach mal schön rauchen aber das wird
auch schwierig jetzt weil die Legalisierung von
Cannabis sich verzögert musste Karl Lauterbach
neulich verkünden Karl Lauterbach der sich um
die drei großen CS der Gegenwart kümmern muss
Cannabis Corona krankenhausreform na und aber
dank Corona ist er jetzt wieder voll in seinem
Element ja gerade in dieser Jahreszeit in der
die Infektionen der oberen Atemwege zunehmen
muss man sehen Corona ist noch nicht vorbei
ich habe gerade wieder eine interessante
Studie aus den äußeren Hybriden gelesen die
besag ja immer hast hör mal da hast du immer
das Gefühl und täglich grüßt das murmelt hier
na die Legalisierung von Cannabis habe ich
mir GT das wird das einzige Projekt bleiben
auf dass sich die Ampel ohne Streit hat einigen
können und wenn sie es nur gemacht haben um den
Söder zu ärgern allein dafür hat sich schon
gelohnt na weil der will gar nicht der will
keine Legalisierung der will ein Verbot er
der das ganze Jahr über die verbotsparteien
gewettert hat wenn wir das bekommen hat er
gemeint dann haben wir alle also wenn wir da
gender will er auch verbieten und da wir auch
gender wenn das genderverbot kommt dann haben
wir alles gelöst oder Klimawandel Inflation
Staatsverschuldung alles weg weil nicht mehr
geendert wird die Schulden heißen dann nur noch
der Schuld und gut ist na oder so ähnlich der
verbotswetterer was hat er beim politischen
Ascher Mittwoch in Passau losgeledert wir
wollen bei uns keine Drogen auf der Straße
liebe Freundin liebe Freunde na unten spielt
die Kapelle ein Prosit der Gemütlichkeit
und und die jolende Menge hat getobt super
markusz schnell unter tich brunzen so ist
er halt so ist er der Söder er der Herr
Bayern die CSU das ist ja im Grunde genommen
eins kennen wir alle noch von früher aus dem
Unterricht Bayern und CSU das ist
die Symbiose zwischen Baum und
Filz nein Pilz Entschuldigung und
der giftblättrige knollenknöterig
auch bekannt als sabbernde södermorchel ist
durch sein Myzel im Untergrund fest mit den
Wurzeln seines Stammes verflochten so war
das halt 2023 ein Jahr der Widersprüche
ein Jahr zwischen aufklärungsverweigerung und
vergangenheitsverklärung ja früher war alles
besser vor allem war es früher hoffentlich
kommen wir da wieder hin sonst sind wir alle
fort wieso wir sind doch alle da es ist doch nicht
alles so schlecht wie es uns über das ganze Jahr
über eingeredet wurde oder alle drei Tage steht
der DAX auf einem neuen allzeit hoch gut hat die
Masse nichts davon aber egal man muss sich halt
über kleine Dinge freuen können na ich bin schon
froh dass ich es einigermaßen rechtzeitig hierher
geschafft habe heute weil man muss sich ja immer
fragen wie ma ich nehme ich das Auto steh es
im Stau mit der Bahn auch schwierig weil da
muss ich erstmal den aktuellen streikkalender
studieren ob überhaupt irgendwas fährt wenn
weselski der Teufel der König der streikpfosten
was will er er will mehr Geld nein gibt's nicht
hat der Bahnvorstand gesagt der im Jahr der
höchsten Verspätungen ever erfolgsabhängige
Boni in Millionenhöhe eingesagt hat sag ich so
deeskaliert man im Tarifstreit na und die Bahn
und dann und dann ist sau blöd ne die Bahn
wenn sie nicht fährt muss ich mir am Bahnhof
ein Leihwagen nehmen mit dem ich dann wieder
im Stau stehen kann KZ entschuldigung das bin
ich da habe ich nein das ist das das war der
inflektiv ne weil den kennt man noch aus Walt
Disneys lustigen Taschenbüchern und die lese
ich zur Entspannung immer ganz gern wenn ich
mich durch ein paar Tageszeitungen gepflügt
hab immer gern paar Seiten Donald Duck und
den inflektiv den finde ich toll weil der so ganz
kurz komplexe Gedankengänge ausdrücken kann für
die ich sonst ewig in die Tasten Hämmern müsste um
auszudrücken dass mich etwas total anwiedt mit dem
inflektiv reicht mir ein einfaches kotz oder spei
oder WK die Streiks die Stre noch nie gab es so
viele Streiks und warenstreiks wie in diesem Jahr
nicht nur bei der Bahn der öffentliche Dienst die
Pflegekräfte das Bodenpersonal am Flughafen die
Busfahrer die Lockführer die Fachkräfte in den
Kitas der Einzelhandel alle haben gestreigt
die Franzosen schauen seit Anfang des Jahres
ungläubig über den Reihen zu uns rüber und sagen
ala guck mal die Kartoffeln was machen die denn da
mus die Streiks haben dann sofort die
Mittelstandsvereinigung der CDU auf den
Plan gerufen und deren Frontfrau Gitter
konnemann die immer so bisschen an Gundel
Gaukelei erinnert die dauernd versucht dagober
Dack den Glückstaler zu mopsen Reisch Gitter die
geistige Untermieterin von Friedrich März ja ja
auf den komme ich noch paar mal heute Abend und
die
hat die hat im Zuge der Ausstände angeregt
über eine Verschärfung des Streikrechts
nachzudenken wenn dadurch die kritische
Infrastruktur bei uns bedroht wird Gundel
erstens streiken ist ein Grundrecht
zweitens die kritische Infrastruktur
wird bei uns dadurch bedroht wenn man Teile
von ihr an die Chinesen verramscht wenn man
Krankenhäuser
wenn wenn man Krankenhäuser und
Bildungseinrichtungen kaputt spart
oder einem windigen hütchenenspieler wie
ren Benko auf den Leim geht das gefährdet
bei uns die kritische Infrastruktur
aber doch keine Streiks verschärfungör
Verschärfung des Streikrechts ha damit brauchst
du den Franzosen nicht zu kommen ne die waren
dieses Jahr alle paar Wochen mit hunderttausenden
auf der Straße weil macron es gewagt hatte das
Renteneintrittsalter von 62 auf 64 Jahre anzuheben
und das auch schon ab 2030 da ist der Franzose auf
der Zinne weil er sich sagt Arbeit ist das
was uns auf dem Weg zum Leben im Weg ist was
sag was sagt der deutsche oh je noch
mehr leben da kommen wir ja nicht mehr
zur Arbeit es ist wirklich war Streik
und haben alle gejammert oh dieses Land
kann nur noch Stillstand das stimmt doch
nicht es war doch viel los in diesem Jahr
es hat sich so vieles bewegt okay nicht
unbedingt im Fußball also das war gut
doch einmal hat sich was bewegt im im DFB
Pokal und da auch in die richtige Richtung
insarbrücken
h die Bayern Goliath gegen David
also ich wollte das Spiel erst gar
nicht gucken da habe ich doch ich
hat so einen schönen Abend das war
herrlich in der Champions League auch gegen
Manchester schockverliebt rausgetuchelt mit
0 Z3 und ein zu ein vier Gegentore von
mir mir zum mir kriegen vier habe ich auch
gesehen habe ich auch gesehen hatte
ich schon wieder Spaß na gut dann war
halt wie immer z a haben sie sich wieder
gerumpelt na weil die Dortmunder zu doof
waren das hat mich wieder so geärgert
weil der Söder vorher noch gesagt hatte
die Dortmunder sind F zu blöd für die
Meisterschaft das hat der auch noch recht
behalten schnaup Rumpelfußball aber egal
ich sag nicht aufregen e im nächsten Jahr
ist bei uns Fußball Europameisterschaft das
do super oder ne na ja geht mir draußen auch
so wenn ich fah bei nach den nächsten nach
den letzten beiden testpielen da sagen viele
schon können wir das ganze vielleicht noch
absagen aber immer dieses Gewimmer oh wir
können nichts mehr Fußball können wir nicht
mehr nicht mal die Frauen okay Olympia geht
jetzt ne weil ein alter weißer Mann das Amt des
Bundestrainers übernommen te Horst rubesch mit
ganz klaren Ansagen hey Mädels macht wie wir
damals Flanke man KS ich k ein Tor na und bei
der bei der bei der Leichtathletik WM haben
wir keine einzige Medaille geholt wir können
nichts mehr e hallo wir wurden in diesem Jahr
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte Basketball
Weltmeister und
und im Fußball geht nichts mehr hey die
U17 Europameister und Weltmeister in einem
Jahr es geht doch was da war doch glämer
und wir wollen doch immer glämmer und glemmer
hatten wir in diesem Jahr es kam hoher Besuch
König charlesi hat uns beehrt war sein
Antrittsbesuch in Europa also eigentlich
wollte er zuerst nach Frankreich aber da waren
gerade wieder Proteste mit den gelbwesten und
die haben n gesagt was wer soll kommen Charles H
der Mann wird dieses Jahr 75 und arbeitet immer
noch das ist schlecht für die Moral dann kam er
halt zu uns wir waren wieder nur zwei Wahl aber
egal alle haben sich gefreut großes Staatsbankett
in Berlin die Prominenz trat sich auf die
Füße auch die altkanzlerin erschien und kaum
betrat sie den Raum haben alle geseuft [Musik]
sie und dann ist was interessantes
passiert Charles fuhr mit dem ICE
von Berlin nach Hamburg also
der Kunde war ein König und
und und oh Wunder der ICE kam auf die Sekunde
pünktlich an das erste Mal seit Eröffnung der
Strecke ich habe ja gesagt also schöner wäre
es ja wenn bei der Bahn generell mal der Kunde
König wäre aber es ist halt wahrscheinlich
zu viel also ich war in diesem Jahr ich war
viel mit ihr unterwegs ich habe alle Ausreden
durch Verspätung durch einen vorausfahrenden
Zug Verspätung durch einen entgegenkommenden
Zug unsere Fahrt verzögert sich durch einen
langsam vor uns fahrenden Güterzug verspätete
Bereitstellung des Zuges fehlendes Personal
durch einen verspäteten Zug aus früherer
Fahrt weichenstörung Stellwerkstörung
Signalstörung verspäteter Personalwechsel
spielende Kinder am Gleis ausgebrochene
scharferde niedrigpannung niedrigpannung
in der Oberleitung erhöhtes Fahrgast
aufkommen
[Applaus] erhöhtes fager erhöhtes fager auf
die neulich kam im ICE die Durchsage Störung
am Triebkopf wollten viele gleich eine neue me
Debatte aufmachen obwohl obwohl der Lindemann
von Rammstein gar nicht im erteil saß Ende
Juni wollte ich von Bremen zurück war ein
sauheißer Tag war Sommer zwei Stunden stand ich
auf dem Bahnsteig bis der Zug endlich kam Grund
Tiere im Gleis hab gesagt ja ich vermute mal
Mücken das das einzige was sie sich bei mir
nicht getraut hatten im Februar bei dichtem
Schneetreiben war böschungsbrand man sagt ja
immer man sagt ja immer
man sagt ja immer am Zustand seiner Bahn und
am Zustand seiner Fußballnationalmannschaft
erkennt man den Zustand eines Landes ha ja
aber am Zustand der Bahn kann man ja schön
sehen wohin es führt wenn ein Land über 20 Jahre
lang auf Verschleiß gefahren wird wenn man eine
schwarze Null oder deren Nachfolge Fetisch
schuldenem für die ideologische Maxime der
Daseinsvorsorge hält Schuldenbremse wir stehen
vor historischen Herausforderungen wir haben
multiple und globale Krisen die Amerikaner nehmen
370 Milliarden in die Hand Pumpen sie in ihren
Inflation reduction Act um dadurch Investoren
anzulocken die in nachhaltige klimafreundliche
und zukunftsweisende Industrien investieren
die Engländer investieren Milliarden in
zukunftsfähige Antriebe bei uns kommt Christian
Lindner und hockt auf dem Geldsack immer so
wird es nich aber bitte habe ich mir wo soll ein
wirtschaftliches Verständnis auch herkommen beim
Lindner
mein
Schluck keinerlei Erfahrungswerte noch nie was
geleistet in der Arbeitswelt des freien Marktes
und wenn er mal was probiert hatte dann ist
er krachend gescheitert Millionen schwer mit
seinen Startups dann kam er irgendwann ins
grübel sagt ich kann wohl wirklich nicht was
mache ich denn jetzt gut man kennt den alten
Spruch ne wer nichts wird wird wird wer gar
nichts wird wird Betriebswirt ist ihm dieses
auch misslungen macht er in Versicherungen
doch am Ende welch ein Glück reicht es
für die Politik und da hat und das hat
Gere und jetzt kommt von ihm nur müsschen
sparen wir müssen sparen wir müssen sparen
schon Helmut kohbs und Angela Merkel
na ja hatten diesen irglauben wie eine
Monstranz vor sich hergetragen aber für den
daraus resultierenden desolaten Zustand des
Landes da werden natürlich nicht die
stillstandsterroristen der zweimal 16
Jahre verantwortlich gemacht es geht auch
nicht hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht in
einem richtungsweisenden Urteil bestätigt
man darf nicht zweimal wegen der gleichen
Tat vor Gericht gestellt werden und
wer heute heißt natürlich wer ist
geht einfach jahrzehntelange aussitzerei wer
war der habbe das ist alles oder der muss
für alles herhalten Dauerregen schneeaos
Hochwasser od hab gucke mal du hast die
so bologaes auf die Krawatte gekleckert
od hab Fußpilz Bluthochdruck Hämoriden
alles der Habeck die Flüchtlinge covid-19
der Klimawandel der jüdische Weltkongress
und die Hochfinanz Bill Gates da war der
Harbeck zum Schüleraustausch in den USA
Praktikum in seiner Garage gemacht damit Bill
Gates in aller Ruhe Säuglinge verschleppen
konnte um sie Jahre später mit biontec zum
Impfstoff für die coronamafia zu verarbeiten das
war das war der Harbeck die französische
Bettwanze wer hat sie nach Paris
eingeschleppt is der borgenkäfer für alles
verantwortlich der haweg und seine grünen klar
dass da viele gleich zu Beginn des Jahres gesagt
haben berlin braucht endlich eine neue Regierung
und hat erfüllt Berlin hat in diesem Jahr eine
neue Regierung bekommen also die Stadt Berlin
und wieder mal eine groko möglich gemacht durch
Franziska GII als wiederholungswahlverlierende
Zeit regierende als exoberbürgermeisterin
auferstanden als Ruine jetzt ist
sie jetzt jetzt ist sie Wirtschaftssenatorin sie
hatte ihren Platz als regierende geräumt mit den
Worten ich werde gehen aber nur um zu bleiben h
mal dabei haben wir doch in diesem Jahr gesehen
dass Frauen Gespür haben dass sie genau wissen
wann es Zeit ist zu gehen die ehemalige Minister
Präsidentin von Finnland s Marin batsch zack weg
war sie in Schottland befand die Premierministerin
Nicolas stin nach 8 Jahren oh bevor ich in
uhaft muss in ist enough und in Neuseeland
verabschiedete sich die Regierungschefin ychinda
Adern nach nur 6 Jahren mit den Worten ich kann
nicht mehr mein tank ist leer was hätte ich
mir bei uns einen solchen Satz nach 6 Jahren
von einer bei uns amtierenden Regierungschefin
gewünscht aber was meinte Angela Merkel nach
6 Jahren mein tank ist leer na und fahre
ich eben noch 10 Jahre auf Reserve weiter
und und
den und den übrig gebliebenen
Sulz im Tank dürfen wir jetzt
auslöffeln na trotzdem hat sie noch Fans also
ein paar ewig unbelehrbare sissiisten gibt's
noch sieht man immer im Juli in bayut
wenn sie alljährlich den grünen Hügel
hochwatschelt na um sich oben mit den anderen
Wagner Söldnern zu treffen da stehen sie
immer und da stehen sie immer da hey da
stehen die Fans immer strohbütet hinter
dem Trassierband Frau Merkel Frau Merkel bitte
hallo komm selfie das war so schön als sie noch
im Amt waren da ist nichts passiert das war
so schöne Zeit das hat der Wähler gutiert
der sich danach zurücksehend weil im Trubel der
Transformation der Zeitenwende der permanenten
Umwälzungen da ist der deutsche Bürger wie
Saskia esken es neulich feststellte erschöpft
und veränderungsmüde so veränderungserschöpft
das wäre für mich das Unwort des Jahres so aber
deswegen wieder zurück zur groko ja das das wä
gut als mit die Meckel hatte da hat das nicht
geben wie jetzt da hatte me ke Ukraine und ke
Dings im nahosten da hat's ke grüne ge guck
dir doch jetzt mal die Stromrechnung an mit
dem Meckel da haben wir billiges Gas in der
Pipeline gehabt weil wir uns noch gut mit dem
Russer verstanden haben mit dem Meckel da hatte
wir ke Inflation da hatte wir nich jetzt haben
wir nich als wie Probleme die hatte wir bei der
merk nicht und wenn sie paar ge hät dann hat
sie wenigstens nicht versucht sie zu lösen das
war
wirklich es war schöne Zeit aber was kommt jetzt
egal was sagen viele Hauptsache eine Ampel
ohne die Grünen ja habe ich gesagt gut aber
wenn grün an einer Ampel fehlt dann hat man
an den Kreuzungen nur noch rot oder gelb also
Stillstand dann fährt gar nichts mehr und
wenn an einer Kreuzung ohne Schilder die
Ampel total ausfällt dann gilt laut
STVO rechts vor links na aber Angela
Angela Merkel wirklich ein Phänomen ne
in zwei Programme in all den Jahren haben
ihr gereicht sie kennen mich und vor
allem mit mir bleiben Sie immer in der
Gegenwart dafür bekam sie in diesem Jahr
die höchste Auszeichnung der Republik das
Großkreuz des Verdienstordens der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland in besonderer Ausführung am Band
gut Bande ist die einzige Bezeichnung die
ich in dem Zusammenhang gelten lasse ne
aber aber wofür den Staatspreis von
Nordrhein-Westfalen hat sie dann auch noch
bekommen für ihren Einsatz in der flüchtlingskrise
2015 für ihren ein also für ihren einen
Satz wir schaffen das und nun macht mal
wobei einen Orden hätte sie schon verdient
gehabt dafür schon vor über 20 Jahren erkannt
zu haben dass man einen wie Friedrich
März politisch kalt stellen muss den
Orden mal ganz
ehrlich den Orden würde sogar ich ihr
überreichen gutes Volk sieht anders ist klar
viele wollen einen Neuanfang mit Fritze
Merz als Kanzler der läuft sich ja in
jeder Bundestagsdebatte warm neulich erst wieder
als der Kanzler seine Rede an die Nation also
seinen Versuch einer Rede an die Nation also sein
behelfsrädchen ich habe bei dem immer der läuft
do noch mit so ein Button rum da steht drauf ich
ich lerne noch und da hat sich da hat sich der
März aufgeplustert am Pult sie können es nicht
und Scholz sitzt auf der Regierungsbank grinst
hilflos vor sich hin glotzt auf sein Smartphone
anstatt mal zu einer Gegenrede auszuholen meine
Güte habe ich mir gedacht wenn ein Herbert
whner noch im Bundestag sitzen würde der hätte
aber h der hätte aber mal auf das märzche
sie können es nicht zurückgedonnert mann mann
sie wissen doch gar nicht nicht einmal
wie nicht können geht und dann hat er
nachgelegt dann hat er nachgelegt der
März gesagt sie sind nur ein Klempner
der macht zeigt zum einen wie gering er den
hartarbeitenden Mittelstand schätzt zum anderen
gab es gleich einen veritablen schitzdaum der
Bundesverband der Klempner und Installateure
hat sofort losgekoffert von wegen er würde sich
verbitten die sei ein ehrbares Handwerk Friedrich
merärz Friedrich merärz bei dem er
sich immer fragt was ist bei diesem
Mann schief gelaufen im Leben wo ist der
im Sauerland kurz hinter Brilon mal falsch
abgebogen um Sachen loszulassen wie die
werden doch wahnsinnig die Leute wenn sie
sehen dass 300.000 Asylbewerber abgelehnt und
ausreisepflichtig sind aber nicht ausreisen
die sitzen beim Arzt und lassen sich die Zähne neu
machen und die deutschen Bürger nebendran kriegen
keine Termine an dieser Aussage stimmt nichts aber
auch gar nichts das macht dem großen Sauerländer
in seiner postfaktischen Welt aber auch überhaupt
nichts aus er behauptet einfach mal na getreu dem
leicht abgewandelten sarazinmotto das wird man
ja wohl noch lügen dürfen ich habe mir was ist
hier los Zahnarztpraxen werden geflutet ich musste
neulich zur Zahnreinigung hat um 10 Uhr ein Termin
morgens bin vorsorglich schon um 7 Uhr hin und
habe die Schlange stehenden ausreisepflichtigen
Asylbewerber gesucht niemand da bin ich ins
Kaffee dann war ich pünktlich zum Termin hat die
zahnreinigungsfachkraft nur gemeint sie trinken
ganz schön viel Kaffee nicht ja das sieht man ich
habe mirag mal ist es das was der März wirklich
denkt dass Menschen die tödlich Gefahr einer
mittelmeerüberquerung in Kauf nehmen um sich
in Deutschland die kariös bedingte zahnfeule
am Backenzahn hinten rechts sozialschmarotzen
behandeln zu lassen glaubt er das er der mit all
den anderen üblichen Verdächtigen doch immer ganz
vne dabei ist wenn es darum geht zu brandmarken
von wegen ja es geben ja überwiegend nur junge
Männer alle bis an die Zähne bewaffnet an welche
Zähne
ich denke die haben kaum noch welche es gab auch
gleich Widerspruch von der bundeszahnärzte kam der
Typ erzählt völligen Schwachsinn natürlich gab
es auch sofort welche die den cduchf in Schutz
genommen haben vorne weg die Presseabteilung
der CDU die Bildt nur einen Tag nur einen Tag
später groß auf Seite 2 jetzt reden die Ärzte
März hat Recht die Ärzte es war ein Zahnarzt
aus Olpe im Sauerland der Friedrich März
schon mal persönlich behandelt hat und der
zufälligerweise auch noch aktives CDU
Mitglied ist das gibt natürlich einen
veritablen neutralen Kronzeugen ab glaubwürdig
auch aber dann hat März gleich nachgelegt ja
für zwar noch geduldete aber doch irgendwann
ausreisepflichtige sollten die medizinischen
Leistungen drastisch eingeschränkt werden am
besten nur noch Sachleistungen das neue Zauberwort
na Bezahlkarten sollen her digitale Chipkarten
die von den Behörden ausgegeben werden digitales
bedürfnismanagement [Musik] in in unseren Behörden
ich sehe den Amtsleiter schon vor mir wie er am
Faxgerät [Applaus] steht welchen Knopf muss ich da
drücken damit mir das Ding die chipkatte Ausdruck
Sachleistungen im Gesundheitswesen wenn jetzt also
einer mit akutem Blinddarm in die Notaufnahme
kommt dann überreicht ihm die Stationsschwester
ein Skalpell Bindfaden Nadel beiholz Flasche
Whisky zur Betäubung und die OP Anleitung jetzt
helfe ich mir selbst aber März hat unter seinen
barmherzigen unionschristen wackere Mitstreiter
Jens Spahn z.B neuerdings auch migrationsexperte
der hat angeregt dass man schon auch mal phisch
Gewalt anwenden müsse an den Grenzen um
illegale Flüchtlinge an der Einwanderung
zu hindern zur Abschreckung ja ich vielleicht
sollten wir ihn persönlich mal als Statue in
die Hafeneinfahrt von Lampedusa Stellen wie den
Koloss von Rodos ne da drehen die alle die kommen
freiwillig ab und sagen nee so wichtig ist uns
das mit den Zähnen auch wieder n in der in der
in der Migrationsdebatte überbieten die sich
ja mit tollen Vorschlägen ne ab nach Ruanda
mit geflüchteten oder nach australischem
Vorbild von 2001 auf Inseln unterbringen
die nicht zum eigenen Land gehören das wäre
auch was für uns hat detleev Seif von der CDU
angeregt ja tolle Idee nur welche nehmen wir die
orgneinseln die verröer sült würde ich vorschlagen
gehört gehört zwar noch uns aber das würde mir
gefallen als erstaufnahmelager die Sansibar da
fühlen sich die Afrikaner gleich heimisch mit
solch wen Ideen loten die Konservativen immer
mehr aus wie weit sie sich noch an die
Niederungen des rechten stammtischrands
anwanzen können dann stoßen sie mit dem Knöchel
an die selbsterrichtete Brandmauer die ist nur
so hoch die wird auch nicht höher damit man sie
leichter einreißen kann na und dafür hat die CDU
sich ja in diesem Jahr ihr neues Grundsatzprogramm
geschenkt die Agenda für Deutschland abgekürzt
AFD liest sich wie ein
Manifest aus den frühen 80er Jahren Sozialklimbim
Weg zurück zur Kernkraft Mut zur Leitkultur
willkommen im letzten Jahrtausend erdacht
wurde das moderne Antiquariat vom neuen
Generalsekretär der CDU Karsten Linnemann
dem Einstecktuch von Frieder März aus P derbn
lindemann
Linnemann März Spann Söder hauen einen Klopper
nach dem anderen raus ja sagen da viele die
sprechen doch nur das aus was das Volk denkt
aber ist es nicht so also wenn das was das
Volk manchmal denkt wenn das Blödsinn ist es dann
nicht die Aufgabe verantwortungsvoller Politik ist
dem Volk klar zumachen dass das was es gerade
denkt Blödsinn ist schon Walter schel wusste
vor über 50 Jahren es kann nicht
die Aufgabe eines Politikers sein
der öffentlichen Meinung hinterherzulaufen
und dann das populäre zu tun Aufgabe des
Politikers ist es das Richtige zu tun und
es dann populär zu machen aber auf so eine
Idee aber hör mal
aber aber auf so eine eute wie der März natürlich
nicht die machen immer schön resontiments bedienen
und Ängste schüren weil mit der Angst da kriegt
man ihn immer den Bürger Angst hat man schön
gesehen bei dem Thema im ersten Halbjahr die
Wärmepumpe hey da haben ihn die Grünen aber
auch ein gefundenes Fressen vor die Füße geworfen
oder das Gebäude Energiegesetz grottenenschlecht
kommuniziert weil wenn die Grünen etwas wirklich
saug gut können dann ist es das schlecht
kommunizieren hör mal ein halbes Jahr ein halbes
Jahr haben wir uns selbst gelähmt mit dieser
wärmepumpende Debatte nachdem ein erster
Referentenentwurf von der Regierung an die
Kooperationspartner von Bild durchgestochen wurde
ich will jetzt gar nicht mutmaßen von wem aber ich
vermute mal von der effektivsten Oppositionspartei
die im Bundestag sitzt der FDP von
der von der mittlerweile viele zurecht
sagen die FDP das ist die überflüssigste
Partei seit Beginn der Wetteraufzeichnung ja und
dann oder war die Meldung
raus dann war die Meldung raus dann wurde aus
allen Rohren gefeuert ganz vne dabei natürlich
wieder wer Markus Söder in seinem Leib und
Magen der Bild am Sonntag schon dii Tage
nach dem durchgestochenen Erstentwurf großes
Interview Doppelseite gut Söder braucht immer
eine Doppelseite damit er dem was er auf der
ersten Seite gesagt hat auf der zweiten sofort
wiedersprechen kann ansonsten läuft es immer so
Söder geht ins Redaktionsbüro sagt was er gleich
antworten will und die Redaktion stellt dann die
passenden Fragen dazu Herr Ministerpräsident die
die Grünen wollen ab nächstem Jahr ein Verbot
von Gas und Ölheizungen ein Angriff auf die
mschicht und die sozialschwachen wer kann
sich denn jetzt leisten schnell seine Heizung
auszutauschen darum ging es überhaupt nicht
das war nie ein Thema du kannst solange die
Heizung läuft läuft sie und wenn sie kaputt
ist kann man sie reparieren erst wenn wieder
eine neue Heizung eingebaut werden muss muss sie
zu 65% mit Erneuerbaren betrieben werden damit
unsere selbstgesteckten Klimaziele für 2045
eingehalten werden können aber die Angst war
draußen die Angst war im Land mutti Mutti hast
du schon gehört was die vorh wir soll unsere
Heizung rausreis dabei haben wir doch erst in
den 60er Jahren die Fenster neu gemacht und
und mit Asbest Speicher gedämmt Heizung laufen
lassen dann schalte s uns ab an Silvester und
wenn wir unsere neue Wärmepumpe Dings einbauen
müssen dann haben wir kein Geld mehr dann hab
wir nur noch zwei Möglichkeiten wie me über
den Winter kommen entweder mirfrien oder mir
verhungern
diese diese wärmumpbtez Skandinavien hat
unglaubig zu uns runtergeschaut smöreböre
worüber redet ihr da bei uns in eine Gase
Ölheizungen schon seit 10 jahreen verboten
wir haben Wärmepumpe die funktioniert bestens
bei uns war Angst und dann wieder Panik ich
habe mir so oft kann man denn nicht mal positiv
an die Herausforderungen rangehen die vor uns
liegen ist es nicht auch Aufgabe der Politik
denn Menschen Mut machen sie mitnehmen mit
Lust und Laune Sie neugierig machen auf die
Veränderung an der jeder mitwirken kann ihnen
nicht ständig suggerieren der Klimaschutz sei
für sie schlimmer als die Folgen des Klimawandels
raus aus der Schockstarre weg mit der Angst meine
Güte was haben sie uns vor einem Jahr noch alles
eingeredet spätestens am dritten Advent sind
die Gasspeicher leer dann müssen wir das pkett
rausreisen daheim und verfeuern damit wir nicht
erfrieren und was war die Gasspeicher waren voll
und haben uns safe durch den Winter gebracht
jetzt waren die Gasspeicher wieder prallvoll zu
100,4% keine Ahnung also wo die 0,4%
irgendwo ums Gras zu wärmen vielleicht
noch aber die Speicher wenden uns auch
durch diesen Winter bringen ja aber der
Winter 24 25 der soll ganz streng
wen habe ich im Nostradamus gelesen
was haben sie uns Anfang des Jahres kirre
gemacht die Inflation sie stürzens in den
Abgrund die Inflation geht seit Anfang des Jahres
Monat für Monat zurück ja die sammelt nur neue
Kraft dann die Migration Flüchtlinge
nehmen den deutschen die Arbeitsplätze
weg die nicht besetzt werden können das ist
doch quatsch die zu uns geflüchteten die also
außer die aus der Ukraine die dürfen doch
gar nicht arbeiten ja das ist das Problem
dann schaffen sie schwarz und nehmen der
anständige Deutsche die schwarzarbeitsplätz
Weg
bitte kann man einfach mal hergehen K man
nicht mal zeigen was geht wir können doch
mehr als Selbstmitleid wir können doch was
unsere Tüftler und Ingenieure die bayerische
Firma man in Augsburg die bauen nicht nur LKW
die haben in der dänischen Stadt esessberg eine
gigantische Wärmepumpe errichtet die 100.000
Einwohner mit Energie versorgen wird das war
so ein kleiner Bericht irgendwo versteckt unter
vermischtesag wo waren denn da die bayerischen
wirtschaftsspitzen Söder und eiwanger die mit
stolz geschwellter Brust pressewiksam bei man
zum Posen antraten um in höchsten Tönen den
innovativen Wirtschaftsstandort Bayern zu
Preisen da war nichts wahrscheinlich weil der
eiwanger sofort geknurrt hatte Wärmepumpen da
gehen wir nicht hin das ist grüne Ideologie
das machen wir nicht und der Söder hat sich
ganz schnell hinter dem Baum versteckt den er
vor kurzem noch umarmt hatte na aber okay ist
halt der Söder ne nein bei man sind die
beiden fossile nicht aufgetaucht dafür
immer wieder im Atomkraftwerk Isa 2 so
ist er der Söder ne nach Fukushima hat
er als damaliger Umweltminister noch gedroht
sollten alle Atomkraftwerke bundesweit bis
Ende 2022 nicht abgeschaltet sein dann werde er
zurücktreten und sich aus der Politik zurückziehen
die Ampel hat die Laufzeiten bis Mitte April
2023 verlängert wo bleibt die Erfüllung seines
Versprechens
Mitte April kurz vor der Abschaltung
von Isa 2 hat er Abschied genommen
vom Reaktor das war toll wie er
da stand Sturm um Toast vor dem
Kühlturm mit entschlossenem Blick leni
Riefenstahl hätte ihre helle Freude
gehabt aber [Applaus] [Musik] wier der alles
vorhat mit Bayern seine Regierungserklärung
neulich also ein wünsch dir was der Illusionen
Oberpfaffenhofen soll zum houen Deutschlands
entwickelt werden Bayern soll das europäische
mondkontrollzentrum werden da hat der Mann im
Mond mal laut gelacht ne also eine Teststrecke
für eine Magnetschwebebahn in Nürnberg will er
machen hei was lagern in irgendeiner Scheune im
Erdinger Moos noch verrostete Teile vom Transrapid
ein schwachsinnsvorschlag nach dem anderen aber in
Bayern ist passiert nichts kein hashag Aufschrei
nicht mal einer der kommt und sagt bringen
Sie den Herren bitte wieder auf sein Zimmer na
[Applaus]
Kritik Kritik an ihm prallt ab weil
schuld sind ja immer die anderen also
so die Grünen die Grünen deindustrialisieren
unser Land weil sie es in eine Planwirtschaft
überführen wollen das doch Blödsinn dafür
müssten s doch erstmal einen Plan haben
und Deindustrialisierung da braucht man keine
Politik das schafft unsere Industrie von ganz
alleine bei der Automesse in Shanghai konnte
man den selbstverschuldeten Niedergang unserer
Autoindustrie schön beobachten die deutschen
Hersteller standen mit so paar Elektro SUVs
oren rum dann kam Verkehrsminister Wissing und
der pries Freude strahlend den Relaunch des
verbrennermotors Deutschland ist Technologie
offen da haben die Chinesen mal gelacht der
Technologie ja macht nur so weiter
mit eurer Retro das ist gut für uns da
bleiben wir meldmarktführer dann haben sie
kurz den Vorhang beiseite gezogen dahinter
standen 100 rein elektrisch betriebene mod vom
Kleinstwagen über den Pickup bis zum Kombi war
alles da vor allen Dingen bezahlbar da war
bei uns große Ratlosigkeit angesagt also ja
unsere Automobilindustrie kann halt nur groß
dreieinhalb Tonnen SUVs bei denen der Akku sch
so viel wiegt wie früher in Opel record
wie ihr Flagschiff auf das so stolz sind
der Audi Etron sind alle Wunderwerk der Audi
Etron haben sprachdesigner nicht aufgepasst
Etron kommt aus dem Französischen und heißt
übersetzt dampfender Kackhaufen das istich gut
beschreibt gut und dann gleich dann gleich
der nächste angsthammer unsere Industrie
wird verschärbelt der Verkauf von fiesmann helle
Aufregung nur nicht beim Verkäufer von fiesmann
dem Familienunternehmen aus Hessen na dessen
Vorsitzender also der 38-Jährige Erbe der hat
das ganz locker genommen weil der Käufer Carrier
global machte ein Angebot 12 Milliarden da hat er
mal gelacht na ich habe mir wenn bei uns
so die Deindustrialisierung aussieht so
fröhlich ich habe ja selber ich habe in der
schaffenburg so ein kleines kabaretttheater
und hab mir auch gedacht Briol wenn morgen
früh Walt Disney zu dir käme wir sagen ja
wir hätten als Ergänzung für unser Portfolio
gerne genauowas wie dieses kleine Theater im
Angebot für sagen wir mal 10 Millionen wie wär's
ja gut also da müsste ich schon mal Nacht drüber
schlafen ne mindestens weil wir vorher drei Tage
am Stück durchgefeiert hätten das ist doch völlig
logisch doch einfach sehen es ist doch man
muss doch auch immer bei allen Umwälzungen
das Positive sehen ich war im Sommer in Urlaub war
ich in Kanada und in Kanada ist es anders da gehen
die Menschen aufeinander zu nicht aufeinander
los da kommst du auf dem Campingplatz sofort
heißt es hey where from how you doing have a
good one take care bei uns gehst du raus und
sagst guten Morgen schon kommt die Reaktion
was soll an dem Morgen für mich gut werden
klar auch in Kanada gibt's Probleme aber dort
sagt man sich oh hier ist ein Problem wie lösen
wir es bei uns heißt ah jetzt ist ein Problem
wem können wir es in die Schuhe schieben und
dann und dann muss man wieder von den Problemen
die nicht gelöst werden ablenken und Ängste
schüen ganz vorne dabei in diesem Jahr Hubert
eiwanger der der Kracher des Jahres alsdem im
Wahlkampf mal kurz die Luft ausging ne
hat er also mit der CSU gemeinsam neuen
angstpfeil aus dem Köcher gezogen der Wolf
der Wolf ist wieder da der Wolf verbreitet
Angst und Schrecken wir haben 30 registrierte
Wölfe in Bayern und da war der eiwanger in
seinem Element der Wolf der Wolf gefährdet
die schofherde vor allem gefährdet er die
enbeuerin obknollen so for ob knnollenag wen wen
die almbäuerin nein den Wolf den Wolf obknollen ob
das heißt letal entnehmen Hubert versteht niemand
ich sag obknollen ein Glück ein Glück dass sein
Bruder Waffenhändler ist da bleibt wieder mal
in der Familie na und die Wölfe also die Wölfe
waren wirklich da hatten sie auch noch die Spur
eines Bären entdeckt okay in Berlin hatten sie ein
Löwen der sich dann als Wildschwein entpuppt
hatte aber sie hatten die Spur eines Bären
im kiemgau der Boulevard hat sofort getitelt
die todestatze von Traunstein und gleich schon
wieder Angst ich habe das in Kanada erzählt auf
dem Campingplatz bei quebeck saß mal abends so
beim Lagerfeuer rum mit ein paar Einheimischen
haben so ein ow roast gemacht und dann hi er wie
ist bei euch so wie ist bei euch so ja wir haben
bei uns ganz schöne Probleme in Deutschland also
der wollt die Wölfe wir in Wölfe wir haben 3
30 Wölfe in Bayern 30 wöl und in Bayern hat
man auch noch die H die die Spur eines Bären
entdeckt die haben sich vor Lachen gar nicht
mehr eingekriegt die Marshmallows sind ihnen
in die Glut gefallen einer hat mich gleich
angestupst ah ihr hab ja so ah ihr habt die Spur
eines ja guck mal da hinten da stehen 12 das
ist das ist so
wohltun das ist so wohltuend diese kanadische
Gelassenheit habe ich auch gesagt mehr davon ne
wir wollen auch gute Nachrichten und die gibt's
ja zum Glück die Regierung kann wieder Kredite
aufnehmen weil die schufah Auskunft wegfällt das
wäre aber auch zu viel der Rechnerei gewesen na
und rechnen können wir ja nicht mehr wie uns
die jüngste Pisa Studie gerade bescheinigt hat
die Bildungsmisere die muss jetzt die eine von
der FDP ausbaden die in den zwei Jahren ihrer
Amtstätigkeit durch nichts außer ihrem Doppelnamen
aufgefallen ist Bettina stark Watzinger die steht
jetzt vor dem Pisa disaster und befindet h schöner
Schiefer Turm das hatten guute Architekten damals
die Griechen es ist halt Bildung es ist Hal so
man muss halt da auch wieder geldbildung kostet
halt aber das Thema zum Ausklang des Jahres die
Haushaltssperre der Haushalt wofür ist noch Geld
da für die Rüstung natürlich Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius ist sofort erstmal gleich nach Kiev in
geheimer und hat weitere Hilfen zugesagt das ist
auch gut so weil für die in der Ukraine wird es
sowieso schwer genug wenn im nächsten Jahr Donald
Trump nee ne lieber gar nicht dran denken ne ne
viele sagen ja auch W der nicht der hat mehr
Anklagen an der Backe als seinerzeit el Capone
aber seine umfrageerte gehen durch die Decke gut
halt man kennt ja die 64000 eurofrage bei Günther
ja auch was grenzt an absolute Dummheit
Mexiko und Kanada und in [Applaus] Sachen
in [Applaus] aber in Sachen Ukraine Unterstützung
steht der Scholz wieder im
Feuer wegen seiner zögerlichen
Haltung im Nacken sitzt ihm Marie Agnes Strack
Zimmermann Panzer Agnes die immer so tut als
wird sie jeden Leoparden eigenhändig in die
Ukraine fahren wollen mit Tony Hofreiter
als Beifahrer und die die Waffenlieferungen
zu Scholz haben sie nur gemeint an seinen
Worten wird man ihn messen da meint einer
wie der Scholz nur wie soll ich wissen was ich
sage bevor ich höre was ich denke nein er war
in einem war immer klar keine deutschen
Alleingänge wir stimmen uns mit den
Verbündeten ab so war's auch los ging es mit
den we Schützenpanzer mit den Schützenpanzer
ging es los haben die Franzosen gesagt okay
wir liefern unseren späpanzer den Radpanzer
amx10 von Citroen ist ein bisschen blöd im Gefecht
wegen der Hydropneumatik ne weil es dauert immer
paar Minuten bis er hochgefahren ist ist beim
Überraschungsangriff von Nachteil dann haben
die am gleich gesagt okay dann liefern wir unseren
Schützenpanzer Bradley Pit und noch am gleichen
Abend haben wir gesagt gut dann liefern wir 40
marer kaum waren die auf dem Weg schon hieß es wo
bleiben die Kampfpanzer wieeder Abstimmung mit
den USA die haben gesagt wir schicken unseren
Abrams also war bei uns frei der Weg für ein
Bataillon Leoparden kurz zuvor noch von kin
Göring Ecker gesegnet und Wasser war noch nicht
trocken schon hieß es wir brauchen Kampfjets
aber da haben wir gleich abgewunken ne ne ne also
unsere Tornados ne die wollt ihr nicht wirklich
haben vielleicht als Attrappen ja aber gut
dann wenigstens Kriegsschiffe und da kam der
stellvertretende Außenminister der Ukraine
mittlerweile Botschafter in Brasilien m ganz
sympathischer Mann der geborene Diplomat und hat
gemeint wir haben eine 1000 km lange Küstenlinie
und da habe ich eine kreative Idee die deutschen
bauen die besten U-Boote der Welt die u212a wenn
wir davon eins bekommen könnten werde uns sehr
geholfen hab viele gesagt e melniik weißt du
was so ein U-Boot kostet Peanuts ihr habt do noch
die Sektsteuer da wä es doch ein leichtes und dann
kam dann kam die marineexerten haben den
Kopf geschüttelt hab gesagt e Ukraine ihr
hattet noch nie ein U-Boot die Ausbildung das
dauert Z bis 3 Jahre egal her damit ja al wie
soll es denn hinkommen ins Schwarze Meer die
Route ist bekannt ja ja und die führt durch
den bosperus aber den hat doch der Erdogan
für Kriegsschiffe gesperrt die russischen
liegen davor auf Rede und rosten vor sich hin D
haben ganz Schlaue gemeint aber es ist doch ein
U-Boot das fährt doch unter Wasser das sieht
doch keiner dann biegt am Goldenen Horn ab und
hängt im Fangnetz fest Jaen s mein kein Witz
hab me man können Sie auch auf dem Landweg
versuchenag die u212a wiegt 1800 Tonnen und und
muss über die Katen wir sind
doch nicht bei Fitz caraldo
und im Sommer war dann bei uns klar
Sommer war Wahlkampf Hessen und Bayern die
uvertüre dazu war die Erdinger Rede von Hubert
eiwanger mit der der festzeltmessias für die
schweigende Mehrheit die Demokratie zurückholen
wollte danach ging es ungebremst weiter mit
seiner flugblattaffäre aus der Schulzeit
riesenaureger kam der sö gesagt 25 Fragen
habe ich ihm gestellt muss mal bis Donnerstag
beantworten hat er aber nicht also weiß ich
nicht ist mir nicht erinnerlich ich war auf
keinem Gymnasium war gar nicht auf der Schule
kenneen keine Lehrer schon der er konnte sich
an nichts erinnern gut es ist klar weil er hat
außerhalb seines eigentlichen wirkbereichs
auch wirklich sehr viel zu tun muss ich zu
ja ja
ja der Mann im Mond hat gelacht also ist ist
wirklich es ist einfach muss ich zu allem
äußern obwohl ihn kein Mensch danach fragt
na vor allem wenn es um die Grünen geht und
gegen die geht's bei ihm immer das ist bei
ihm pathologisch da musst du den den kannst
Du so schnell triggern du musst nur hing
sag HSI geh mal her hupsi hey hupsi upsi
Grün in der Welt in der Welt hat er in
einem Interview gesagt was uns droht
wenn die Grünen Wärmepumpen kommen ich habe
es dreimal gegenecheckt es ist jetzt keine
Satire ich zitiere dann werden Fernsteuerungen
eingebaut in in die Wärmepumpen wo man aus der
Entfernung die Temperatur ablesen kann und ich
sage Ihnen eins dann wird ein ideologischer Rad
in Berlin die Heizung zurückdrehen in München
ferngesteuert aus der Hauptstadt da haben wir
nicht wei hin da werden sich Räte bilden
und diese bürgerräte werden dann mit einer
begrenzten Menge Energie hantieren dürfen und
bestimmen dann wie warm es in ihrer Wohnung
ist
was hupsi was Räte werden sich
bilden die Bolschewiken kommen in
die Hauptstadt hupsi hast du hast
du noch mehr Blödsinn auf Lager
ja ich bin Jäger wo ist der nächste
Bock den ich schießen kann nach den
dann dann nach
den nach den bayerisch hässischen Wahlen war es
dann wie immer es gab nur Gewinner die CSU hat
gewonnen obwohl sie die zum zweiten Mal infolge
das zweitschlechteste Wahlergebnis der Geschichte
eingefahren hatte 37%. 0,2% verloren ich habe
dann mal gerechnet ich habe mir wenn das in dem
Tempo so weiter geht dann dauert's nur noch 825
Jahre bis die CSU in Bayern unter der 5% Hörde
landet auf den Tag freue ich mich heute schon
na die die Grünen haben sich dann dafür gefeiert
dass sie in Bayern und Hessen das historisch
zweitbeste Ergebnis eingefahren hatten nur die
FDP da war nix da gab's keine Party in Bayern
aus dem Landtag geflogen gut dort hatten sie
ihre Rolle als außerparlamentarische Opposition
schon früh angenommen nach hab flächendecken
plakatiert servus Zukunft sie hätten wissen
sollen dass man in Bayern servus sowohl zur
[Applaus]
Begrüßung
ne als auch zur Verabschiedung sagt sie haben sich
dann halt für letzteres entschieden und Hessen ja
da war aber eigentlich schon klar wie es
ausgeht dank der SPD bitte wie konnte man
so blöd sein im Februar die damals schon
völlig unbeliebte Nancy fazer ins Rennen
zu schicken wo doch der gesamte Boulevard nur
darauf gelauert hat sie stürzen zu sehen erst
hieß es holt uns den Skalp von der lamch
den haben sie dann bekommen dann ging es
weiter wo bleibt der Skalp von Nancy
fer na eigentlich wollten Springer und
Co von Anfang an den Skalp von Olaf
Scholz aber da ist nicht so viel zu
holen die AFD hatte im Wettbewerb nur ein Ziel
in beiden Bundesländern Nummer 2 hat in Bayern
nicht ganz gereicht aber stärkste Opposition und
da sitzen jetzt gestalten drin im landag na wie
der eine daniel hemba wurde sogar steckbrieflich
gesucht wegen Volksverhetzung ne unter zeichnet in
Gästebüchern gern mal mit sie Keil läuft ab
und zu mal so durch die Straßen gut Zerrung
wahrscheinlich na allo das Hetzen hat er gelernt
bei seiner schlagenden Verbindung Teutonia Prag
ich habe ja mal in Würzburg studiert und
nicht von ungefähr war damals immer unser
Motto lieber ein Geschwür am afterter als
ein deutscher Burschenschafter aber für ihr
Ziel
aber für ihr Ziel Nummer 2
zu werden da gab die AFD alle
opferlegenden wurden gestrickt Alis Weidel
musste eine Veranstaltung am Tag der Einheit
in mödlerreut absagen weil Drohungen gegen
ihre Familie mit der sie in der Schweiz lebt
in lesbischer Beziehung mit einer aus Sri Lanka
stammenden Frau und zwei adoptierten Kindern
also klassischer Lebensentwurf der tolerant
weltoffenen AFD Gemeinde sie musste sich
dann sie musste sich dann in ein
safeeh Zurückziehen dort stand sie
unter sicherheitsbedingtem Hausarrest da hat
die Partei getobt ja das sieht man was passiert
wenn der linke Mob wütet unsere Parteichefin
wird eingesperrt blöd nur dass die Paparazzi
die bedrohte Weidel dann nicht also im
safeeh gefilmt hatten sondern in einem
öffentlichen Strandrestaurant auf Malle okay
das wä von deutschen keine Gefahr aus gegangen
die Latschen in die Schinkenstraße kommen hinten
mit 2,8 Promille wieder raus aber am Strand wie
auf dem Präsentierteller hat die niemals James
Bond Filme geschaut der Feind kommt übers Meer
in einem Schnellboot der discovolante muss
nur drauf halalten zu und schnell abdrehen
Froschmänner die sich durch die Kanalisation und
den Fettabscheider hinterrückst auf die Terrasse
schmuggeln um sie mit einem Messer im Handumdrehen
wegzucheln kurz danach hat man sie an derisette
kann gesichtet in vertrautem Plausch
mit dem deutschen Steuerflüchtling
Theo Müller von Müllermilch dann gleich
das nächste Opfer ihr kovorsitzender
Tino schrupala der hatte Wahlkampf Ingolstadt
wollt gerade auf die Bühne dann Schwächeanfall
nein natürlich kein Schwächeanfall weil ein
deutscher AFD Politiker schwächelt nicht Stress
hat er gehabt haben viele gesagt gut habe ich
geglaubt schupalla ist gelernter Malermeister
der hat dauernd Stress weil er die Fassade
der Partei immer hellblau überdünchen muss die
Grundfarbe
die die Grundfarbe aber nach kürzester
Zeit immer wieder durch die Raufasertapete
schimmert Schwächeanfall nein muss ein
Anschlag gewesen sein auf Oberarm wurde
eine Einstichstelle festgestellt eine linke Wespe
eine Grüne Hornisse war es eine
Attacke mit dem blashoher Gift vom
südamerikanischen pfeilfrostcht NX die Ärzte
hatten sofort mitgeteilt dass ih Blut von ihm
keinerlei toxische Substanzen nachgewiesen
werden konnten das hat mich jetzt wieder
überrascht denn wenn man im Blut von
AFD Funktionären etwas mit Sicherheit
nachweisen kann dann sind es Spuren von
dem Gift dass sie täglich verspritzen die
AFD
sonst sonst habe ich mir auch gedacht ja die
AFD mit also mit immer diese sehensucht nach
dem ewigen gestern aber nicht nur bei der AFD
überall als ich von Kanada zurück war Wahlkampf
ich fahre bei mir durch die
Stadt schaffenburg aschebch
auf einmal will ich abbiegen auf
ein Riesenplakat mit Franz Josef
Strauß der jetle diesmal doch schlimm
Halluzinogene in der Lüftung gewesen
toller slogen fand ich auf dem Wahlplakat
wir wollen mit rechtsradikalen Narren und
Extremisten nichts zu tun haben löblich löblich
aber Franzel warum hast du dann jahrelang den
chilenischen Diktator pinochetofiert und
jeden afrikanischen Despoten willkommen
geheißen war das Motto deiner Partei nicht
immer rechts von uns ist die Wand ja das
waren die guten alten Zeiten ne da war
rechts die Wand und links die Mauer ne
ja Ja sagen wie viele e sagen jetzt
vieleol den Spruch hast schon vor über
10 Jahren gemacht sag ich ja nicht nur
den was soll ich denn machen wenn wenn
sich nie was ändert wenn ich aus der
Moderne der kanadischen weiten in die
deutsche Engstirnigkeit zurückkomme und
als erstes sehe ich Franz Josef Strauß
schnau mit Franz Josef Strauß werben als
Zeichen des Aufbruchs in die Moderne in
Bayern geht es das ist das ist das ist [Applaus]
so oh großer Aufreger dort in diesem Jahr
die Wahlrechtsreform die Ampel hat ein neues
Wahlrecht beschlossen also beschließen
müssen weil vom Bundesverfassungsgericht
vorgeschrieben vor über 12 Jahren hatte
Karlsruhe gefordert das Wahlrecht müsse
zeitnah reformiert werden und nun könnte es
ausgerechnet die Partei treffen die die Weisung
aus karlshohe immer ignoriert und blockiert
hatte die CSU jetzt fallen ihr die Überhang und
Direktmandate die gestrichen werden auf die Füße
seitdem drehen die frei ein Anschlag auf den Süden
Bayern wird im Bundestag nicht mehr vertreten
sein na ja Bayern schon die CSU halt immer es
ist n so es wird sich auch ohne Wahlrechtsreform
ig es verändern im Bundestag na wer da jetzt alles
rein will die Freien Wähler fr locken schon
Berlin Berlin fahr nach Berlin das Parlament
wird durchgerüttelt weil eine zweite Gruppe sich
anschickt dort einzuziehen Sarah Wagenknecht will
es wissen kräftig unterstützt von ihrem Ehemann
Oscar lafontain da kam es in diesem Jahr sogar zu
einer Aussöhnung mit seinem alten Widersacher
Gerhard schrödermer Oskar wollen wir un sie
wieder ver wir haben do beide was geschafft ne ihr
hab die SPD platt gemacht und du die [Gelächter]
Linkspartei hast du einen guten Rotwein da ne
aber die Frage ist wie wird sie heißen die neue
Partei ist das wichtigste wie wird sie heißen
die weniger linke Linkspartei sozial national
garantiert grantenfi haben wir vielleicht
bald zwei linke Parteien im Bundestag die
eine linke und die andere linke es hat mich
gleich an den großartigen Film das Leben des
Brian erinnert an die judäische Volksfront und
die Volksfront von Judäa vielleicht heißt die
neue Partei auch oraa also Oskars Rache an
allen oder PLO Putin liebchens org Team oder
oder einfach Liste Sara gab's ja in
Österreich auch mal ne Liste Sebastian Kurz
aber Liste Sara für Deutschland also LSD ich weiß
es nicht natürlich hat sie auch gleich Neuwahlen
gefordert wie der Söder alle V Neuwahlen ist
neue Ideen müssen her mal über den eigenen Teller
rausschauen andere Länder zeigen uns
doch längst wie man vieles viel besser
macht von der Bildungs über die
Energiepolitik bis zur Rente aber
wir aber wir meinen immer noch dass wir
mit erhobenem Zeigefinger dem Rest der
Welt zeigen müssen wo es lang Zug gehen hat
unsere Außenministerin jettet rund um den
Globus will den Amis zeigen wie Klimaschutz
geht mit den Vertretern von climate justice
nahmen sie dort medienwirksam den Bus für die
Strecke von Austin in Texas nach Houston 260
km hat gesagt ja so geht Umwelt so spart man
Kerosin mhm dann war sie in Houston und hatte
ein Problem denn der regierungsflieger wartete
dort schon auf sie weil er ihr leer hinterher
fliegen musste über das Klima wird ansonsten
gar nicht so viel geredet n erst jetzt wieder
also bei der Weltklimakonferenz da in Dubai da
gab's ja sprudelnde Idee also eher sprudelnde
Ölquellen ab am Ende ein von der OPEC abgenicktes
unverbindliches abschlussprotokoll wie immer halt
ne im nächsten Jahr sieht man sich ja wieder in
Aserbaidschan für die nächste Absichtserklärung
nee Klima hab ihr gemerkt in diesem Jahr das
Thema ist durch ne also wir sind erschöpft
will keiner mehr hören und wenn dann sagen alle
Klima da kommt gleich wieder Verbotspolitik ja
geht halt manchmal nicht ohne na in diesem Jahr
haben sich alle gefreut das Ozonloch schließt
sich früher als erwartet warum weil es seit
den 80ern ein FCKW Verbot gibt viele Verbote
sind doch auch von Vorteil ein Rauchverbot in
gaststätdten in Flugzeugen und Zügen hätte es
mit einer Freiwilligen selbst Verpflichtung der
Tabakindustrie nie gegeben und ohne ein Promille
Alkoholverbot am Steuer würden die Leute
heute noch jenseits der 1,5 Promille durch
die Straßenschluchten sausen unangeschnallt
natürlich weil ich lass mir das ohne Gurt
fahren nicht verbiete man muss ja schnell
in den Wald um dort Ölwechsel zu machen was
heute was
heute was heute leider verboten ist
nein Verbote gab's schon immer schon
in der Bibel zehn Stück da hießen s halt
Gebote ne die wussten schon damals dass
man immer positiv formulieren muss framing
halt nein ohne Verbote geht es nicht hätten
wir wieder hätten wir wir eine Republik ohne
Verbote dann hätten wir Anarchie also genau
das wovon die verbotsbekämpfenden Konservativen
träumen aber wir waren echt gefangen in diesem
Jahr wir hatten Verbote wir hatten Angst wir
hatten Krisen zum Glück hatten wir auch die
Klatschblätter die uns über die wirklich wichtigen
Krisen informiert haben wo sitzt Prinz Harry bei
der Krönung von König Charles werden die Pochers
gemeinsam Weihnachten feiern was interessiert mich
das die Mutter der Katzenberger Iris klein
oh sie hat sich die Hupen neu machen lassen
muss ich das WIS neulich gehe ich durch die
Fußgängerzone pusht mein Handy gucke ich da muss
der Wendler umziehen al was interessiert denn mich
wohin das Arschloch zieht na Hauptsache Hauptsache
irgendwohin Hauptsache irgendwohin wo
er kein Netz hat und dann natürlich
Till Schweiger unsere große Hollywood Hoffnung
der Mann der einen Gesichtsausdruck beherrscht
und die Zähne beim Reden nicht auseinander kriegt
er musste dieses Jahr viel PR machen hatte zwei
Filme am Start und nicht so gute Presse na außer
natürlich in seinem Leib und magenblatt der
Bild die haben ihn gefeiert oh Till Schweiger
wird politisch weil er genuschelt hatte was
sie dort gerne hören wollten die die Grünen
sind die größte Gefahr war werden nicht vom
verfassungsschuss beobachtet wenn wenn es in
ström regnet und der hab ich s und tremmt und W
es nie mitnehmen W Ex füze fahren D B schön von
oben bis und diese klimakaoten die W eigenhändig
von der Straße rupfen sie Haut am Asphalt danach
danach danach begeisterte Reaktionen
bitte Herr Schweiger bewerben Sie sich
als Bundeskanzler sie wären genau
der richtige meine Stimme hätten
sie die CDU Hamburg und die CDU Rheinlandpfalz
haben ihm Aufnahmeanträge geschickt jemand wie
sie der immer kartext spricht belebt
jede Diskussion die Politik braucht
Menschen wie sie was erwartet die
Rettung unseres kriseneschüttelten
Landes von einem behelfsmemen mit dem IQ
eines kneckebrots das kann nichtin kann
nicht jedes
Mali jedes Mal wenenn Schweiger wenn irgendwas
sag kommt mir sofort wieder in den Sinn schweig
aber eine nicht unerhebliche Masse glaubt das
mit ihm stön es kann doch nicht was dass wir
allen Erz wir sind doch nicht ganz blöd also ist
also ist die Verblödung bei uns wirklich schon S
weit fort nach ein paar Jahrzehnten privatem
trashchfernsehen mit dem senderauftrag die
blöden noch ein Stück blöder zu machen es kann do
nicht sein dass ist so schnell wir sind doch nicht
alle wir haben doch also zwischen den Ohren
damit können wir doch immer noch denken also
wir könnten doch es ist doch nicht so dass wir
alle dann kommt mir immer das alte Sprichwort so
dann kommt mir immer das alte Sprichwort in den
Sinn die Mutter der Dummen ist immer schwanger
[Applaus]
und und die Mutter sagt ihren
Kindern alles wird gut wird alles gut die
Ampel ist bald Geschichte soag ja und dann
wie schaut's dann bei uns dann aus nach
umjubelten vorgezogenen Neuwahlen bildet
sich eine neue Regierung angeführt
von der wiedererstarkten Union die
sozialdemokratische spurenelementspartei
Deutschlands die SPD stellt sich mit
bereitwillig in staatsbürgerlicher
Verantwortung als Juniorpartner zur
Verfügung Bundeskanzler Friedrich März begrüßt
seinen FZE den Finanzminister Olaf Scholz mit
warmen Worten sie können es nicht und genau
deshalb brauchen wir einen wie sie nehmen
sie nehmen Sie die Rohrzange und machen Sie
sich an die Arbeit nimmt ihn beim Wort und legt
sofort ein milliardenschweres Sondervermögen
Wirtschaft auf unter notständlicher Umgehung
der Schuldenbremse Begründung wir leben in
einer neuen Zeitenwende unser Land braucht
einen trippelwumps Außenminister Alexander
dobrint von der CSU nein nein nein nein nein
wir wollen jetzt wirklich nicht wissen
was ein Außenminister dobrint betonen
könnte Energie und klimaschutzminister
Jens span freut sich darüber dass durch
das Sondervermögen wärmeubvention der Rückkauf
des deutschen pumpenpioniers fiesmann möglich
gemacht werden konnte der wärmepumpendeal in
Höhe von 59 Milliarden das sein schließlich
Peanuts im Vergleich zu den Unsummen die
ein ehemaliger Gesundheitsminister für
sinnlose maskendeals in der coronazzeit
aus dem Fenster getanblert hätte Umwelt
Umweltministerin Julia Klöckner verkündet
bei einer Pressekonferenz mit Nestle die
Vereinbarung der trinkwasserprivatisierung
die den Haushalt enorm entlaste was der
neue Zukunfts und transformationsminister
andreas Scheuer ausdrücklich begrüßt den
Herausforderungen im Bildungswesen
nach dem Pock begegnet die noch
fortschrittlichere fortschrittskoalition
mit ihrem neuen Bildungsminister Till
[Musik]
Schweiger die Wirtschaft hat sofort gefeiert die
staatskutsche ist wieder zuverlässig besetzt im
komfortablen Coupe sämtliche Arbeitgeber Bände die
beständig gegen das Wagendach klopfen und laut hü
hü rufen um den auf dem Kutschbock sitzenden
also der Union zu zeigen wo es langzugehen
hat ab und an muss die Kutsche an die Raststation
sofort kommt brav die SPD vorbei um die Pferde zu
striegeln und ihnen Wasser zu geben die Grünen
dürfen die garanien an der Zollstation Gießen
an der die tapferen wagenknechte versuchen die
braunen Gartenzwerge der AFD zu halbieren womit
der Kutscher gescheitert ist halbiert haben sie
nur uns greint der im Sandkasten versonnen an
seinem schuldenbremsenförmchen Spielende Christian
Lindner schöne neue alte Welt wde eldes hxli
anlässlich seines diesjährigen 60 todestages
sagen alles wieder beim alten aber gut ist wenn
es der Souverän also der Wähler so will dann ist
es souveräner Wille es gehören ja immer zwei dazu
die die es machen und die die es mit sich machen
lassen die die Spalten und die die sich spalten
lassen die die hetzen und die die sich aufhetzen
lassen it always takes to Tango es sind nicht
nur immer die da oben die da nein es sind auch
also die also die wir da unten und wir müssen
doch
wir müssen doch zusammen halten wir müssen
zusammenhalten wir müssen Solidar wir müssen doch
gemeinsam m es kann do nicht so aber gut schon
Thomas hops wusste homo homini lupus est also
der Mensch ist dem Menschen ein Wolf was Wolf wo
ob Knollen sofort nein HSI das ist doch auch keine
Lösung wir haben doch nur uns wir wir sind's doch
wir wir müssen doch wir wir müssen doch zusammen
also wir wir entscheiden doch wie es weitergeht
ne ach so ja ja dann dann gehen wir mal davon aus
das 2024 wieder genauso bescheu nee das 2024 ein
bisschen weniger kann so sagen dass 2024 wird freu
[Applaus] also also dann h dann machen wir
dann machen wir das Beste draus vielen Dank
[Musik] [Applaus] [Musik]
danke schön danke schön vielen Dank
danke [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]
schön [Applaus] [Musik] [Applaus]